hi this is presh talwalkar
the train fly problem is one of the
classical mathematical puzzles
can you solve it
consider two trains that are a hundred
miles apart from each other
the trains move towards each other at a
constant speed of 20 miles per hour
in between the two trains is a fly and
the fly zigzags back and forth between
the two trains at a speed of 40 miles
per hour
so the fly starts at one train goes to
the other train and keeps on going back
and forth
the following animation gives you a
rough idea of the path of the fly
the puzzle is what is the total distance
that the fly travels
for the purposes of this problem you
want to assume the fly changes speed
instantly and it keeps going back and
forth between the two trains
infinitely many times until the two
trains meet
so your problem is to figure out the
total distance that the fly travels
there's an amusing story about this
puzzle
the american mathematician john von
neumann was asked this puzzle at a
cocktail party
the story goes that he instantly gave
the answer
the person shocked asked him oh so you
know the trick to solve this puzzle
and his answer was
what trick i just solved the infinite
series
so give this puzzle a shot
you can either try and solve it by the
infinite series or you can try and
figure out what the trick is
when you're ready you can keep watching
the video and i'm going to present the
solution both the trick and the infinite
series
all right
let's try and figure out the total
distance that the fly travels
you really don't need to do any
complicated math even though it seems
like a difficult problem
so the first observation is that the two
trains move towards each other at 20
miles an hour
we can think about this that the two
trains have a combined speed of 40 miles
per hour
20 plus 20 is 40.
the next observation is that it will
take the trains
to cover 100 miles
at 40 miles per hour it will take them
two and a half hours to cover this
distance
so now we've almost solved the puzzle we
figured out that the two trains will
meet in two and a half hours
and here's the final observation
if the fly is moving at 40 miles per
hour for two and a half hours
that means it will travel
two and a half hours times forty miles
per hour which is a hundred miles and
that's it the fly travels a distance of
a hundred miles even though it travels
this very complicated path of going back
and forth
so you actually don't need to model the
path you don't need to calculate any of
the distances in between you just need
to calculate the total time it takes for
the two trains to meet and then multiply
that by the fly's constant speed of 40
miles per hour
so it's a very cool trick and it can
stun people that you can solve the
problem so quickly
so now let's solve the problem the hard
way using infinite series
the first thing you have to do is
calculate the distance the fly travels
the first time it meets the train going
the other direction
so we'll calculate this that the train
and the fly together are moving at a
speed of 60 miles per hour because it's
20 miles for the train and 40 miles for
the fly
so how long will it take them to meet
what's the distance the fly will cover
well to cover that hundred miles
traveling at 60 miles per hour
we know that it will take a time of a
hundred divided by 60.
we then multiply that by the 40 miles
per hour that the fly travels at
to compute the fly travels distance of
200 divided by 3
or 66 and two-thirds miles
another way to think about this is the
fly travels
twice as fast as the train
so they're going to meet at two-thirds
of the way on this hundred miles which
is
66 and two-thirds or 200 over three
so that's the first distance the fly
travels when he meets the first train
now we need to compute
the new distance when the fly is
traveling the other way to meet the
other train
so the first thing we do is we
compute that the two trains are now at a
distance of 33 and a third miles
we've already calculated that one train
moves
33 and a third miles so that means the
other train also moved that distance and
the distance between them is 33 and a
third miles
so now we basically have the same
problem except everything is reduced by
a third the distance is one-third
and so what will be the distance that
the fly covers well we can do the
calculation but it'll actually turn out
intuitively that the fly is going to
cover one third of the distance it
covered before
so this will be 200 divided by nine
and in fact now we'll have a reduced
problem again the distance between the
trains will be reduced by a third and so
we can compute an infinite series where
each time we have a factor of one-third
when we solve for the total distance we
will get that the fly travels for 100
miles
of course this method is a lot more
complicated than using the trick
and there's a lot more room for air
along the way
so it's still instructive to go over it
but it's important to know the trick and
you should keep an eye out
for it
so that's the train fly problem
thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory
you can catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions which you can follow
on facebook google plus and patreon you
can also catch me at preshtalwalkar on a
bunch of social media places and please
check out my books i've written several
books about math and very cool topics
like the one in this video
you can check out a link for all my
books there is a link in the video
description